Adrian Peterson will be back in
Washington again this year the team
picking up the option on the second year
of a two-year deal and he just keeps
going the guy's gonna be 35 this season
and he just keeps going he and Frank
Gore as long as someone's gonna give
them an opportunity to play for a team
run the football
give them reps give them handoffs
they're just gonna keep piling up yards
and yards and yards and Peterson has
said multiple times Chris that he wants
to break Emmitt Smith's all-time rushing
record nemyt told us at the Super Bowl
hey he wants to be alive when it happens
well even though Frank Gore is closer I
think the one guy on the planet right
now who has the best chance to catch
Emmitt Smith is Adrian Peterson yeah I
mean I would say that too but I still
think there's just too much meat left on
the bone for him to do it now I do think
he has a chance to pass up Frank Gore
you know I think he's got a little more
left in the tank maybe than Frank Gore
does but Adrian Peterson yes I mean at
14,000 216 yards you know he's still
4,000 a little more than 4,000 yards
away from him and Smith and I don't know
if he's got that much time because right
now I mean where thousand yard seasons
or you know they're dicey I don't think
they're gonna happen for Adrian Peterson
with the roll he's gonna play at this
stage in his career so he might be able
to get to like maybe get to Walter
Payton territory but I think that's even
dicey at this point too regardless it
doesn't matter what he's doing is
amazing and he is one of the best
running backs in the history of football
for my money
he's more than eleven hundred yards
behind first-ballot hall-of-famer Frank
Gore and if you say otherwise he will
fight you all a favor
Frank Gore he's got it he still got a
thousand yards to go to catch Barry
Sanders but the one thing about Adrian
Peterson and again the great unknown
here is who will continue to give him
opportunities there was a question as to
whether or not Washington really would
pick up the option but I think you have
to forget the birth certificate and you
just have to look at the guy yeah he can
still do it he can still get it done and
we always root for great stories it
would be a fabulous story if Adrian
Peterson just keeps plugging away and
plugging away and plugging away and ends
up with 18,000 three
56 even if it takes six or seven more
years to do it and he's playing into his
40s like Tom Brady we've seen this guy
recover from injury and he has lost
nothing I mean he's not the game breaker
he was up ten years ago but compared to
other running backs he can still get it
done he yeah and you know he he gets
banged up like they all do but when he's
healthy man he give him the ball and let
him go well and he keeps fighting even
when he gets banged up at this age you
know what did he deal with like a little
foot injury there at the end of the year
or something with the leg and he just
continued to play you know he's made out
of stone he really is I mean this is one
of the freakiest athletes to ever play
in the sport you know Mike I don't know
if you've ever met him but of course you
know Adrian Peterson would you meet him
in person he's just like it's just like
I don't even it's like metal wire and
muscle and you could like muscles in his
ears and you shake his hand he's like
he's famous for like breaking your you
know me I got these big meat cleavers
right for her hands I shook his hand and
damn he tried to break my damn hand and
I was like okay am I about to get in a
handshake match here with Adrian
Peterson but he's just that type of guy
and you know yeah you've got giant freak
hands like that claw machine right
that's what your hand is that's
questioning when you see my leg you're
gonna do it next week every day you know
it's he phone home you're gonna do it
next week and you're gonna say you got
that long ass et finger man does that
thing glow red at times only when you
get too close it's it's a warning sign
to get you away yeah you know Adrian
Peterson just to hit that on again you
know he'll go down for me as one of the
greatest players I've ever seen in
person in my life and I know I said the
other day that for me he's the top 3
running back in the history of the sport
but he's one of those guys and they're
very few of them even in my my 8 year
NFL career even being in my dad's game
where I watched him on the field I was
with the Tennessee Titans in 2008 and I
remember the Minnesota Vikings came to
town I went oh my gosh you know first
off he's bigger than you expect them to
be and he's so fast and so explosive and
so violent in his prime especially he
was you know a man among
boys in a game that's full of you know
big-time men and that's that's where I
just I'll never forget watching him
reverse the field and the Tennessee
Titans game I'm talking about and then
run back the other way and score a
touchdown and we had like one of the
best defenses in football and he did it
like without breaking the sweat and
that's why he's just amazing to me yeah
and I I just hope it keeps going and I
hope that he is able to play and
continue to find opportunities to play
long enough to get to his goal of
passing Emmitt Smith because I guarantee
you he still wants where do you put a
mic like in the Mike Florio rankings of
running backs I mean I know you I don't
know if you think he's top three like me
but I'm sure you think he's probably at
least top five or six like you know
Emmitt Walter Barry Sanders Adrian
Peterson you know Jim Brown that Errol
Campbell that group where do you where
do you go in there I'd say three or four
yeah and I'm reluctant to say Barry
Sanders three cuz he's been passed by
Frank Gore but Barry Sanders Chu chose
to only play a decade in the NFL can you
imagine if he had played as long as he
could have what he would have had yeah
when he walked away from the game he
would have been consensus best running
back of all time but I would put Adrian
number three or number four and
especially if he continues to climb this
all-time rushing list because that will
mean he will have done very special
things late in his career at a position
where for most guys the wheels come off
once they get to 30 even if they only
can make it to 30 a lot of these guys
can't even make it to 30 so what he's
doing is incredible what Frank Gore has
done is incredible especially in this
era of pass happy NFL offensive
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports